how you feeling yeah yeah there's three
Carmichael's about to get onto
Carmichael Street
what's your calorie count looking like
today Nina they would find their way you
know why cuz your car light goes
[Music]
alright alright alright alright welcome
to day one in Montreal how'd you guys
sleep good I did not sleep well me mess
up well know you were up late too
all right well we had a fun morning just
getting ready not really not fun haven
you this homework and we rocked that to
some music and now we're gonna get some
breakfast evasion
that's daughter yeah exactly we're gonna
go to get the best smoked meat in the
world copy first Vanina and then smoke
me you never had smoothie it's yummy
Dave why here we go
oh we found the Starbucks or Nina it
says cafe star 5 Nina's gonna get our
coffee so all the signs and everything
are in French here and I scan me that's
a good thing that I know some French -
goodbye because these guys they would
find their way they would find their way
you know why does your car light goes I
love it okay Nina Nina Carmichael you
get your coffee you ready Peyton gets
his coffee no no water orange juice
nothing
[Music]
I got the mint peppermint mocha when
they got the caramel brulee and Hayden
got the cappuccinos juice Pacific flash
orange juice yeah me how's it company
now Nina was getting a little bit angry
hungry angry so now she has her coffee
she's not hungry anymore how is it yummy
what just happened Nina made a big mess
oh it's spilled on your scarf it's a
little bit embarrassing you know Nina's
sometimes a very messy person but it's
okay we love her right what's your
message Nina why chose a copycat
okay don't make a mess again Nina just
just let's scarf maybe need to go on the
garbage Nina we love you you dropped
your scarf again
alright let's go we have got coffee in
our bellies Nina's feeling better warm
Hayden's feeling mad Kate is feeling mad
we're gonna go get our smoked meat best
smoked meat in the world I don't even
like smoke me but we're going for Nina
so she can have it we have to get there
by 10:30 a.m. that's when they start
serving the hot meat and you have to get
the fatty version that's what sells out
first that's the most delicious tasting
even though I don't like the fatty
version of meats but that's what we're
gonna get hey didn't follow behind let's
go to Schwartz's deli
[Music]
we are getting close we came for Nina
look at that smile that's why we drove
here for Nina to see that smile taste
that food yum yum yum yum yum yum yum
yum mmm
there it is Schwartz's best smoked meat
in the world what look at the meat
that's in crazy meat Nina's excited look
at that smile that's that's that's worth
the price of admission okay let's go get
our sandwiches
[Music]
this is our table agents ready for his
food
okay cheers Schwartz's deli yummy I
didn't nobody even clicked my glass here
we go no no no yeah cheers whoo cheers
to you guys
oh look I can see Haiti through my glass
Wow Haven's food just came
there we go this is what we came for
okay Nina
[Music]
how're we doing mr. pop that in poutine
for practice tre time to dig in to this
scrumptious
[Music]
we're very dependent
Wow
[Music]
well Haven is not a fan
here have some poutine have some poutine
tell us sit down with poutine put it in
put it in now oh yeah the cheese and
usually yummy yummy yummy
so hey does not depend but Nina and I
Tyrell join ours
[Music]
alright back on the streets of Montreal
it's noisy out here why is it so noisy
you're feeling full how you feeling full
house hating feeling ready we're not
getting it yet but we're getting it soon
the special candy in Chinatown that
we're gonna get soon
I'm feeling very fall I need to walk off
this food I had to finish hating poutine
on top of my sandwich next stop dr. dan
basilica the most famous church in
montreal and one of the most famous
churches in canada so let's see it
[Music]
all right we made it outside the famous
check out your damn church let's go
let's go let's go
[Music]
I had a puzzle okay was it going
[Music]
you always wanted to come here because
you did a puzzle maybe you're in the
puzzle now the next one
[Music]
what do you think of the church shaving
pretty cool eh
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah not yeah we have more to see first
before the Dragon's beard candy that's
coming up later all right next up we're
going to explore some old montreal the
old town see what it has to offer
Tesla Airport taxi is Old Montreal
[Music]
what's up hey another Channel what's
your name
Rafi Rafi I like it we do what's your
favorite video actually all the videos
about success I love it
nice this Nina my wife my son there you
go we're just traveling in Montreal
today you enjoying your tour cool
Cheers Marche I think it's a market when
Dina and I were in London there was huge
protests and when she got stopped by
jakub members they need to take if we
had a fire fan and we're here munch Iran
they have a protest happening around fur
not having fur so we seem to go where
the protests are
we attract protesters no they want
animal rights what do we want and
alright so when do we want it down
pretty small protest stuff is like 15
people but you know we showed up in the
cold to have their piece say what they
want to say so so got it okay continuing
on let's go okay so next up we are on
the hunt for Dragon's beard candy this
is legendary thing they do in China
right Nina no it's not it's a legendary
thing that Canadians say is done in
China it's just out of Nina's town but
everywhere else it's legendary Chinese
candy and inside there's peanuts and
chocolate yeah it's something else
caramel something like that anyway I
don't really know where it's where it is
it's just in Chinatown so I gotta find
it there's one legendary guy here who
makes it we got the smoked meat for Nina
and we got the Dragons beard for Hayden
and I might have some - yeah
maybe it's a lot baby you know just
we're really here for hated okay we're
almost at Chinatown let's find out
Dragon's beard I like how the Holiday
Inn has a little Chinese pagoda there at
the top that's pretty cool okay where I
brought the end to the gates of
Chinatown Montreal we're almost here
we're getting close this guy's name is
Johnny chin we're looking for Johnny
chin give us her Dragon's beard candy
come on Johnny
boom Valhalla barb the dragon all right
here we go good job Nina we found it oh
it smells good in here that's it that's
how you make it hey look at that nice
this unusual candy was once made only
for the Emperors of China during state
banquets dragons are a Chinese imperial
symbol and since the Emperor's candy
resembles a long white beard the king be
called dragon three candy look at the
detail to the hair lines yeah very sweet
too sweet for you you're there go I'm
gonna buy another box the next box is
just for me though right
that's a good snack we had to submit a
lot but not this I should have into a
stream huh those are called Dragon's
beard candy you want a dumpling go go go
get dumpling oh I might have bubble tea
I'll only have bubble tea if you sit
inside the dumpling place and have
dumplings okay dumplings in bubble tea
deal lunch time
[Music]
what's H 4 sounds good yummy yummy what
are we getting we're gonna get what
spinach spinach dumpling that's a green
one nice ok and I'm gonna get moving a
huge distance to one time soon okay the
wonton soup has arrived
Nina loves her shoe
the spinach dumplings have arrived
what's your calorie count looking like
today Nina there it is the taste it's
just okay we know that look Nina we know
that look okay it's just okay it looks
cool though
look at that oh you can smell the flower
there just estable and the noodle the
Claire noodle oh no me yeah that's why
it's just okay Hayden's fish moment of
truth
doesn't like the sauce alright how's the
fish [ __ ] thumbs up alright good job
Lena's working on our next trip look how
cute she is all she works I'm feeling
super full
Nina's super full we're gonna keep
walking keep exploring keep it's playing
Montreux and maybe pick up a hot drink
somewhere along the way you're gonna get
a hot drink or no mad mad mad boys don't
get hot drinks hot choc they will see
that if you're mad mad mad only good
good good and happy happy happy believe
believe believe boys get spa chocolate
let's see let's see how it happens now
one more time okay maybe we can keep set
up we'll see we'll see we'll see how you
feeling yeah yeah Nina found something
else what are we looking at Nina what is
this weird dessert oh we should have
come here I would want that I want the
green fog you can make those at home now
[Music]
first first issue the name of the next
tree twins there's three Carmichael's
about to get onto Carmichael Street best
street in Montreal let's see what it
looks like first actually here it is
guys check it out
the Carmichael Street and what's on
Carmichael Street this is a Starbucks on
Carmichael Street that's what I'm
talking about
yeah let's get some something warm
[Music]
Mina's getting the tea I got my caramel
brulee latte havens get in his hot
chocolate with whipped cream small size
there's Hayden's whipped cream that
might be too much whipped cream guys
what do you think what do you think
Caden too much just enough mmm you say
thank you
best hot choc you've ever had all right
give it up for Montreal
[Music]
look at your face
take the cup away taking a big chocolate
mess a big chocolate mess at Cena's face
hey that's pretty clean hello
[Music]
so this is Eaton Center biggest indoor
mall here at Montreal I brought Nina
here maybe do some shopping but she's
not feeling it
she's not feeling it so we're gonna
we're gonna head back to the car head
home
see Timo and relax a little bit before
going out and getting us a specialty
Bake
[Music]
what are you doing you're chilling out
are you meditating on the floor here
what's happening
[Music]
all right made it back to our Airbnb
time to take chemo out in relax a bit
and then go get our big there are two
Montreal shops that fight for who has
the best bagel in Montreal so we're
gonna try one today one tomorrow and
then we're gonna judge Timo somewhere is
there a Teemo Teemo
hello mister Teemo how have you been by
yourself huh
hello Timo sick good boy
let's go
[Music]
all righty so we relaxed a little bit
Tina's going to see
he was blinking friends we relaxed a
little bit and then we decided we're
gonna go out get some food and like I
said there were two really famous
Montreal bagel places that compete for
best bagel in the city I mean we chose
to go to the first one called Fairmount
and I'm going to wait outside with Teemo
how mean I haven going to find a dinner
bagel for all three of us
okay you ready Nina this is the place
this looks very ghetto this looks very
ghetto the house of the original bagel
[Music]
that is a lot of bagels look at this I
know every day there you go hos just a
wall of bagels okay listen let's pick
Nina what are we gonna have it was the
first bagel in space like okay we got
our bagels I got two sesame Hayden got a
chocolate
[Music]
sesame with salmon and new Chiefs
they're open 24 hours a day it's crazy
that was the most packed place I've ever
seen full of bread and we're gonna take
this home try them let you know how they
go
[Music]
okay here our bagels Nina has sesame
seed with salmon I have two sesame seeds
with cream cheese and Hayden has
chocolate chip with strawberry jam okay
just try a single bite before we put
anything on it how was it weird is it
good
okay hold on this is the question is
this the best bagel you've ever tried oh
wow
all right you know what this is the real
moment of truth right here
[Music]
you know it's just okay I don't feel
like it's very expression very dry maybe
I got a different kind too so we're
eating good finish eating then relax the
rest at night
[Music]
so what's an update where did we leave
off eating the vehicles I think wow
Nina's even beagles now that's that's a
whole new thing pika
usual stuff put the ham into bed then we
started lying on the couch and we're
watching reading the beast I've never
seen it if you know what's it come to
life I've seen the cartoon what I'm here
for Nina that's it we're gonna wrap up
the night and then hit the Hitman trail
again tomorrow exciting day planned one
more day in the city for going home yeah
I have a lot of junk we're gonna start
the day with a market maybe at the
market because everyone for poutine and
then bagels afterwards so good times and
salad will find salad so thank you guys
for watching have an amazing weekend
clothes we we believe in you we believe
in you and whatever you want work it
continue to be Marta and I might not say
need the right water I'll see you soon